et il y à un nouvel acteur qui
pourraient ainsi entrer en jeu pour
aider moscou c'est la transnistrie les
explications de bilal tarabel était avec
nous un plateau tout à l'heure pas
transnistrie c'est une république
séparatiste qui se trouve en moldavie
donc exactement sur le sur le même
principe que le dombass en ukraine voilà
on la voit ici à
comment à gauche à gauche de la carte
alors comme vous le voyez au dessin se
trouve exactement entre nicolas yves et
les zones qui sont contrôlés par l'armée
russe au dessus du crâne et la
transnistrie qui est un petit peu plus
loin alors pourquoi la transnistrie
pourrait très probablement venir en aide
à la russie et bien tout simplement
parce que c'est l'armée russe qui
assurent la sécurité de cette région
séparatiste en transnistrie vous avez
quinze mille hommes de l'armée russe qui
appartiennent au commandement régional
figurez-vous le même commandement
régional que la crimée le dombass et le
caucase donc le haut commandement de
toute cette région inclut la
transnistrie on se doute bien en fait
finalement ce sont les mêmes aux
officiers qui décide des mouvements en
crimée dans le combat s'est
éventuellement transnistrie mais si on
va un petit peu plus loin on sait que
les questions d'ordre culturel et
idéologique sont très importantes pour
moscou qu'elles soient exagérées ou pas
il y a l'un des tout premiers dirigeants
du dombass autoproclamée en 2014 qui a
proposé de créer un nouveau pays où une
nouvelle région qui s'appellerait
justement la nouvelle russie est alors
figurez vous que cette nouvelle russie
quelle forme elle avait dans son esprit
et bien elle avait exactement ce qu'on
voit là sur la carte c'est à dire toute
la zone rouge du dombass jusqu'au nord
de la crimée avec la crimée inclus et
cette nouvelle russie elle allait jusqu
en transnistrie alors très brièvement de
quoi on parle avec la transnistrie
finalement elle est la limite entre le
monde romain le monde latin des langues
latines et le monde des langues slaves
qui se trouvent de l'autre côté du côté
ukrainien c'est un tout petit territoire
mais qui concentrent 80% des industries
de la moldavie donc ça pose quand même
un petit problème il est composé d'un
tiers de moldaves d'un tiers
d'ukrainiens et d'un tiers de russes